- We have time for just
one more feel good story.
And it's a good one, y'all.
This is "What I'm Liking".
(upbeat tempo)
(audience cheering)
So this one comes from our
neighbors to the north.
Last year, 14 year old Anthony moved
to a new neighborhood in Edmonton.
His family is from Africa
and his dream is to play for the NBA.
So every day he practiced
for hours in his driveway,
even though he had no net.
Anthony was worried the constant dribbling
bothered his neighbors and sure enough,
one of them eventually confronted him.
But take a look here.
This was a good thing.
The neighborhood came together
and bought Anthony a hoop.
It was such a sweet gesture.
(audience claps)
Many people noticed,
including LeBron James.
Let's get Anthony and his
neighbor, Ian, in here.
They watch on City TV at five PM.
(audience cheering)
What's up y'all?
All right. So Ian, I'm
going to start with you.
You organize this. So
how did it come about?
- Yeah, I just noticed this
kid that was constantly
dribbling his ball up and down the block.
Just being a good kid, playing
on his driveway, dribbling.
And I thought, hey,
let's get this kid a net.
I noticed he didn't
have a hoop to shoot on.
So yeah, I just created a post
on a Facebook community page
here on the north side.
We were just overwhelmed
with all the support of God
and everyone wanting to help this kid out.
- Oh my gosh, I love your
Canadian accent right now, man.
I'm so in love with you. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
And you look like a lumberjack,
this is just like my dream.
This is awesome.
(audience cheers)
It's so awesome.
So Anthony, so LeBron
James saw what happened.
That's super cool, but he's
not the only one, right?
- Yeah. That's true, Ms. Clarkson.
When LeBron James saw that,
that just completely blew my mind.
Like I wanted to pass out on
the spot right there and like,
yeah, that's it right there.
So like, it was just like,
it was kind of insane because
LeBron is like my idol.
He's the person who I've
always looked up to.
And like many people reach out
to like people here at Northside
people kept re-posting it on Twitter.
It was on TSN.
And then when it was on
TSN, I was sweating buckets.
And like,
- Aww.
- It just made me feel good knowing
everybody here has my back
and to making it to the NBA.
Because that's my goal, to
make it to the NBA. It's funny.
(audience cheers)
- That's amazing, and
it's an amazing goal.
Thank you so much, Ian.
And thank you, Anthony,
and good luck getting into the NBA, man.
I'm liking your post right now.
(audience cheers)
Absolutely.
I'm going to have you back on
when you're playing for the NBA.
That's not all, though.
Our season long partner Pilot Pin,
the go-to pin of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
thinks that this story is
as sweet and cool as we do.
So Anthony, in recognition,
they'd like to write you a
check for a thousand dollars
to help you get on your way.
(audience cheers)
(Kelly laughs)
- What?
- Oh my God, I love it, I love it.
- Thank you so much.